hello Conan O'Brien here welcome to
another installment I call them
installments occasionally that's nice
Conan O'Brien needs a friend and uh
wonderful show today I'm sitting here
with Matthew B gorley no no no what is
your middle initial every time I know
this is like the foreign
I wish that was Conan B O'Brien well I'm
afraid to hear what you think the B
might stand for like for you yeah oh wow
Brigadier I'll take it yeah okay what
about for you uh it would be bestest
of all I guess no it'd be Conan Brian
O'Brien yeah that's right Conan Brian
O'Brien
um you know what my middle name is
uh what's it start with it's a c
Christopher that's right yeah Conan
Christopher O'Brien
um and for a while Conan Christ complex
O'Brien
please please that hasn't been proven
only nine doctors have said that
I haven't gone to a tenth yet I did I
was in a writing class uh
as a young man and this woman came up to
me and she said you're you uh you should
be a writer and your name should be
Conan Christopher she kind of was
telling me that my last name sucked you
know that was just and and you know it's
a very it's such a common last name yeah
for the Irish it it basically is
whatever it's uh it's like the Smith of
Ireland you know so
um she was saying you should be Conan
Christopher so this could have been
Conan Christopher needs friend if I had
listened to this woman that's
interesting I don't know Conan's so rare
that it kind of cancels it out yes
that's what I always thought and it
aligns with Conan no Brian my dad
actually thought about these things a
lot he wanted all of our names to allide
he wanted the uh he wanted cone because
the last name was O'Brien he wanted it
to end on a consonant yeah this is the
kind of stuff my dad thought about I get
it um yeah if you never fed us we never
got food but boy it is my first and last
name elide thanks Dad but what's he got
against alliteration because if you're a
Conan Christopher that's got a nice ring
to it as well
yeah but I think Conan O'Brien it just
flows right through yeah no an ending
into a c doesn't isn't as good as an N
into an O hmm yeah
secretly the only reason I've had a long
career in Show Business is because my
first and last name a flow
um that's the only reason we've looked
into it people don't like my comedy
and they really don't find me amusing uh
I'm an irritant but they're just like oh
my God
yeah your name when you really take it
on its own doesn't quite
prepare you for what you're gonna get
right yeah exactly exactly I mean enema
sounds nice you know and then you have
one and you're like I don't ever want to
do that again and pulchritude sounds
horrible exactly means Beauty yes yes
yeah yeah
this is wonderful oh by the way if
you're wondering why uh this
conversation is so boring no no oh boy
Sona is so quiet it's because she wasn't
able to join us for the intro or the
show she's on her way
um and she's going to be here uh for uh
the interview but
um she couldn't be here uh I I don't
know what she's up to you know she's got
a very different life now that's why you
also don't hear crinkling bags
yeah she usually has these crinkly bags
of snacks yeah that's true
can they make a non-crinkle bag for
podcasts they should uh cotton
cotton so you're eating Fritos out of a
cotton out of a cotton bag
we should Market that because you know
there's so many podcasts there's
hundreds and hundreds of thousands of
podcasts everyone's eating snacks
we could Market bags that you put your
snacks in that are made of a very soft
cotton that's not a bad idea and you
know what else is a good idea is we
mentioned the um
Farm Jennifer Garner's pouch food for
children and that's a perfect podcast
food too because it's quiet and you kind
of just suck it like Soylent Green yes
yeah I'm telling you Gorly
I don't know much but I know that this
is a a money making idea yeah
um soft cotton pouches so that podcast
hosts can enjoy snacks while they're
podcasting without that crinkle a little
snack purse a little snack purse that we
market and let's face it
no one else is going to be able to copy
this idea no one else can make something
out of cotton that holds no chips or
Fritos or patented exactly we'll patent
it it's a bag made of cotton it's
brilliant and
um the government US Government the
patent office will back us all the way
and what we do is we put the Conan
O'Brien needs a friend logo on there and
it says you know official podcast snack
purse yes yes these will be available
soon if you see someone eating out of a
a cotton bag that doesn't have the Conan
O'Brien logo on it you know that it's a
bootleg smack it out of their hand smack
it out of their hand
um and then physically attack them yeah
and don't worry about someone seeing you
do it because no one will hear you do it
yeah when you snap when you smack Ace
this soft cotton bag out of someone's
hand it's going to make this sound
yeah that's it you wanna hear it again
yeah
what I didn't hear anything
you bastard you're that's a bootleg
that's a bootleg cotton bag I'll show
you
that was my grandmother's Diamonds oh
I'm sorry I thought you were eating
I thought you were eating corn chips out
of a bootleg Conan I was eating diamonds
you were eating wait a minute why are
you eating is this Marathon Man is this
the ending of marathon why are you
eating diamonds out of a cotton bag
what's your problem and your
grandmother's diamonds yet
what kind of sick freak are you good you
know I've never heard about it I have a
real problem that's your improv good
question I've never thought about it
I've got a problem you're right thank
you for pointing it out I appreciate
that that's funny I love it I'd love to
see you at an improv show and that's
what you do every time wait a minute a a
a a telephone that's really a banana
what are you doing you're right it never
occurred to me I have a problem and
scene curtain comes down why would I try
to call someone on a banana
that's the ninth sketch you ended in a
row Gorly with you're right I have a
problem the world is upside down